is that a comedy or a drama or both
is M night Shyamalan a genius
or a hack
or both
I need some food for thought
whatever happened to that guy
the happening what happened to M night
Shyamalan why is this movie so bad that
it's good is it trying to be so bad that
it's good is it a B movie or is it an a
movie or is it a B movie trying to be an
A movie what is this thing it's an
enigma whatever it is it is most
certainly a hilarious 'ti a movie that's
such an atrocity it's hilarious so let's
talk about it today on my hilarious T
review of M night Shyamalan the
happening
this movie why do I own it because it's
incredible The Happening starring Mark
Wahlberg and Zooey Deschanel directed by
thief one and only M night Shyamalan
this guy has an extremely varying career
I mean think about it he has a movie
that was nominated for many Oscars is a
very underrated and overlooked film he
has a great alien invasion thriller had
a movie that people hated at first
because of the twist ending but has
since developed a cult following
he has another movie that a lot of
people hated it has also since developed
a cult following he's got this piece of
shit and this newer dull boring piece of
shit and then there's the happening a
movie so incredibly hilarious is it
supposed to be I don't even know this
guy has the most varying career out of
any director working today it's actually
kind of impressive even Mark Wahlberg
himself has admitted that he finds this
movie horrible I will quote him directly
and this quote is filled with some words
I don't usually say in my videos to
prepare yourself alright
The Happening fucking it is what it is
fucking trees man the plants fuck it you
can't blame me for not wanting to try to
play a science teacher at least I wasn't
playing a cop or a crook even the poor
man is admitting the fact that the movie
just wasn't what he thought it was gonna
be you can even see him into bloopers on
the DVD kind of talking to M night about
this thing he's not entirely sure about
why would we be asking food if the place
is boarded up nobody's lived here for a
long time what makes you think there's
fresh grocer
two words canned goods it's like they're
humorously arguing about it you know
what I mean like these like I don't know
about this idea and M nights like look
just do it okay see this movie was
marketed as this new thing for M night
Shyamalan it was gonna be rated R very
bloody very violent no more pg-13 scares
you go to this movie and yes it is very
bloody and very violent in that way but
it's also kind of hilarious like you're
not really thinking wow that's really
terrifying you're thinking this movie is
amazing
it's so quotable too I've actually gone
to some of my friends and been like come
on guys take an interest in science
before this movie came out there was
something that bothered me already that
I was like this is not going in a good
direction
check out the tag
line of this movie we've sensed it we've
seen the signs now what's happening
really you're gonna reference your two
most successful movies in your tag line
how stupid is that it's like yeah this
movie doesn't have anything to stand on
let's just talk about the fact that I
made two really financially successful
movies once and we'll put that in the
tagline I mean even on the making of
documentary for signs M night didn't
even want them to put that he was the
director of The Sixth Sense in the
trailer of science he wanted signs to
stand on its own and it did now
originally this movie actually opened
with Mark Wahlberg's character and Zooey
Deschanel's character having this big
fight and it kind of explained why they
were at odds with each other throughout
the movie and I deleted it because he
wanted it to be like us figuring out why
they were fighting which is kind of a
good idea I guess because that way we
can kind of get into the relationship
and see where it's going but at the same
time I wonder if it might have actually
been a better character introduction for
Wahlberg's character then hey guys so
what's going on with all the B's out
there hey guys this B's dying all over
the place
what do you guys think about that I
don't know Albert Einstein said that if
the B was extinct mankind would be
extinct what do you guys think about
that come on take an interest in science
we'll get to Mark Wahlberg's first
lecture in a bit but first this movie
opens with two characters sitting on a
bench and the one actors his name is
Kristen Connelly you may know her from
the cabin in the woods I actually had a
chance to meet this actress
at the cabin in the woods screening and
since M night Shyamalan really inspired
me as a filmmaker with his first few
films I asked her what it was like to
work with him when I brought up the
happening her face like went cold like
she got really nervous like I was about
to insult her or something like I I
don't really know what that means but we
didn't talk about M night Shyamalan that
much let's just put it that way we ended
up talking more about the cabin in the
woods which is what she wanted to talk
about clearly these two girls are
sitting there and she seems to be the
only one who's not affected by this
epidemic that is suddenly happening
around her she has these magic powers
that for some reason I guess allow her
to not be affected by the fact that
everyone around her has instantly
stopped moving and then started walk
backwards and then her friend stabs
herself in the neck and killed herself
that's a little interesting then we cut
to these guys working on a construction
yard and bodies start falling everywhere
people are committing suicide everywhere
this is crazy what is going on but the
problem is it's not really that
frightening it's kind of funny and it's
sad to think that he has all these
masseuse
they're funny but the way they filmed it
and the way the actors are so overly
serious it just comes off as funny now
when I saw the trailers for this movie
there was actually a clip of Shyamalan
in the trailer at the end talking about
how he was like people that came out of
the theater and they were shaking and
they were so upset and disturbed it was
really awesome very happy about it they
seemed like he really was trying to make
a scary thriller but then later on right
around when the movie came out he was
like yeah it's a b-movie you know you're
supposed to be entertained by it it's
like a movie where it's like yeah we're
cheesy we're being that way on purpose
that's that's why I'm well that's right
yes cheesy b-movie because that's how
everyone's gonna think when they see it
the thing about Mark Wahlberg's
introductory lecture is that it
literally spoils the entire movie if
you're actually listening to what comes
out of characters mouths all he's
talking about is how it's a scientific
event that no one will ever be able to
explain and that's exactly what happens
in the movie and it's like it literally
spoils everything it happens I remember
the first time I saw it I was like wait
so basically he just told me what's
gonna happen in the movie right and he
goes on to talk quite often about bees
bees are apparently a reoccurring event
in my hilarious 'ti reviews Thank You
Nicholas Cage the worker man was amazing
hey guys
yeah so soon we get an introduction to
Zooey Deschanel character or Zooey
completely miscast Deschanel her acting
in this movie is so so bad and I am a
fan of hers I mean she is just downright
awful in this movie makes you kill
yourself just when you thought there
couldn't be any more evil that could be
invented during this scene you get the
first little hint of mankind being too
evil when you see the paper that says
kill adelphia and it's referencing how
murder has gone crazy in Philadelphia
you get a lot of hints about that in
this movie that man is encroaching upon
nature and that's not a good thing so
they meet up with John's leg will I ruin
every movie I'm in zamo at the train
station they get on the train they're
hoping to get out of there because
everyone thinks it's a terrorist attack
which you know what that makes sense a
lot of people would think that nowadays
so suddenly the train stops and Wahlberg
gets out and talks to the conductor's
and he's like hey man why'd you stop the
train Philbert where's Phil bird none of
us know where that is
hey you can't just leave us here and the
guys like we lost contact with whom
everyone what a train just stopped going
to its destination if it lost contact
with the people at its destination and
anyone else and just let all of the
passengers disperse into the woods so it
seems like most everyone groups together
at this country diner where we actually
get a kind of smart scene where Mark
Wahlberg shows his mood ring to the
little girl John Leguizamo's daughter he
puts it on her finger and he's like oh
it's yellow that means you're about to
laugh he gets her to laugh there's a
kind of cool little tidbit with that
ring that comes up again later in the
film it's actually pretty neat writing
but that's replaced immediately with a
woman going oh my god oh my god look at
this and then you look at her cell phone
and it's like this incredibly violent
and disturbing video that no one would
ever be like oh hey random person next
to me sitting next to a little girl look
at this life-changing ly violent video
that will haunt you for the rest of your
life it's this guy just letting Lions
bite off his arms it's really funny but
seriously though in real life if you
were sent a video that disturbing would
you look at the random person next to
you as well as the little girl and say
oh my god look at this no you'd be like
dude this is horrible I'm not gonna show
anyone this especially at a restaurant
then suddenly this asian man that
apparently ever wanted the restaurant
listens to its like whatever is
happening it's not happening about 90
miles from here and then everyone just
listens to him and leaves hey guys I
like this guy he understands what's
going on we all need to get about a
hundred miles away from here so let's
all run away
and then we get the introduction to one
of my favorite characters in this movie
and I'm just gonna refer to him as the
hotdog guy this guy's awesome
he really likes hot dogs too we'll get
to that soon so John Leguizamo wants to
go search for his wife which means he
has to go on another car Wahlberg and
zooey deschanel are saying goodbye to
him he lets them take care of his
daughter Wahlberg's like I think we
should go over some probabilities that
probably a good idea right and leg was
almost like there's a 62% chance that
this ain't gonna have happened to us
there's like a 62% check look what I'm
sorry what is it why what like who just
stands there and goes over probabilities
I get that he's a math genius freak guy
who is calmed down by numbers but my
favorite part of this scene it's Mark
Wahlberg's delivery of this line well
you go get you is okay I should have of
course like you can really tell that
wahlberg was like hey night do I really
have to read that in that exact same way
oh yeah you do
great so John Leguizamo then drives off
and we get the incredibly obvious I'm
about to die shot then we get the hot
dog scene now this scene is amazing this
guy he just really freaking loves hot
dogs you like hot dogs right uh-huh
you like hot dogs don't you mm-hmm
you know hot dogs get a bad rap they got
a cool shape protein have to do with
anything mister Shabalin nevertheless
thanks for that scene I like it so John
Leguizamo's in this truck with all these
people then all of a sudden there's all
these hanging bodies in the middle of
the road just hanging from poles and
whatnot the sad thing is is that the
girl screams after we see these bodies
even though there's like a 30 second
period where they're driving along this
road where anyone in this car would be
like hey there are like ten bodies
hanging right there but nobody get like
this really long pan over shot and then
a loud jump scare and the girl go
ah it's like you would have seen those
like a minute ago woman so he tries to
calm her down by telling her a math
riddle a very complex math riddle he's
like if you had this certain amount of
money starting this day and then
continued to double it each day how much
would you have in the end of the month
anyone on the planet knows that more
than likely it's at least more than a
hundred right and she's like it's 30
it's 30 no woman is not 30 besides that
what is the point with all these math
riddles I get it he's a math teacher he
loves math but enough with all the
probabilities and riddles and all this
it's dumb so the gas or whatever they
think it is it's starting to come
through the car the car like crashes
into this tree with this incredibly epic
shot so in the next scene Mark Wahlberg
and Zooey Deschanel and the little girl
are in the car with the hot dog guy and
his wife and they see an army truck
approaching them he's like oh it's the
army we're safe no actually it's a tiny
Adam Sandler babbling about cheese and
crackers cheese and crackers a
shooby-dooby to do
let's go everybody let's go he called
this shit poop so based off the hot dog
guys thoughts about the plants the
plants having something to do with it
Mark Wahlberg starts to figure things
out maybe it could be the plants is it
possible that the plants are upset with
humans and are trying to kill us by
emitting toxins into the air is it truly
possible well think about it that
newspaper said that murders rising in
Philadelphia man the plants are aware of
these things so a large group of people
kind of end up around the same spot as
Tiny Adam Sandler directs them where to
go so as this big group of people are
walking to wherever they're walking they
start to hear gunshots the wind is
starting to attack that's right the wind
is blowing the toxins around and there's
gunshots and screams in the air Mark
Wahlberg goes oh no then Zooey Deschanel
goes we don't know what
oh no well maybe it's the frickin
gunshots and screams lady you think that
might have something to do with it
seriously what a dumb thing to say we're
not gonna be like those
on the news so don't do anything when a
problem happens we're not assholes but
everyone just give me a got-dang second
honey in a second give me a second all
right be scientific douchebag figure out
the variables probabilities
experimentation oh yeah that scenes in
the movie and I'm supposed to be really
intense didn't really work out though
it's just amazingly awesome
so wahlberg is starting to think you
know what maybe when people are grouped
together you know we just split up we
need to get away from groups because
this thing is attacking groups because
the you know we're stepping on the grass
or whatever we're bumping into too many
leaves so we just split up into groups
so at this point in the movie now people
are dying everywhere and Wahlberg is
really starting to think you know what
maybe we're setting off the plants maybe
it's the plants it's probably the plants
yeah we need to get someplace right we
need to get out of here oh crap here
comes the wind the big epic evil wind
scene Emma I tried to make the wind
scary and it just didn't really work out
eventually they've run into these two
kids one of his Spencer Breslin on loan
from abigail breslin who was in signs
and they're just chit-chatting a lot you
know these two kids look like they're
about 14 or 15 years old you know I
don't really understand what they're
doing there they're immensely incredibly
calm for these two kids who are
obviously separated from their families
you'd think that would really be what
they were thinking about like hey
where's my parents where's my sister
where's my brother
where are my grandparents I don't know
something besides oh cool that's a mood
ring let me see that oh wow there's a
kind of clever idea that happens where
they're in a model home and you don't
find out they're in a model home until
after that scene or all the stuff in the
house is fake and you're watching it
like what in the world is going on it
was kind of a clever idea but in the
long run it kind of ended up being a
distraction at the same time in this
scene whoever we get an incredible
moment where Wahlberg talks to a
houseplant and I understand that in this
scene it is supposed to be funny but
that's the Enigma of this movie you
can't always tell like is this supposed
to be funny or is this just so bad that
it's funny and you can't always tell
which one is which we're just here to
use the bathroom then we're just gonna
leave that's okay
so when he's looking down to Haley sees
a whole bunch of people running and he's
like there's too many people over there
oh no there's too many people and turn
up they all stop moving and up there it
is they're done for he turns on a
lawnmower and lets it run
it's the violence in the movie just
isn't scary it comes off as funny then
they run past a sign where the shot
lingers on homes being developed and
everything more man-made problems we get
it Shyamalan the plants are upset at us
they don't like us
so they come upon this house and they're
knocking on the doors cuz they think
maybe there could be some food in there
the little girl is swinging on a maple
tree why would you do that obviously
everyone's freaking out about this plant
thing might not be a good idea to go on
swing in fact Wahlberg says maybe that's
not a good idea I told her just for a
minute what kind of tree is this I think
it's a maple I mean this is like
time-wasting dialogue at this point
during this scene Mark Wahlberg is
trying to convince this guy who's in the
house that they're normal his way of
convincing people that they're normal is
by doing this one Blackwater keep on
rolling Mississippi move won't you keep
on shining on me see we're normal just
an FYI if you ever want to convince
someone that you're normal don't do that
then all of a sudden the kids like turn
into rioters they're like show your
faces open the door we just want to get
some food for this little girl you
pussies like where in the world did that
come from it was almost like M night was
giving us a reason to not be that sad
about the fact that those kids are about
to get shot
yes the children are killed they're all
killed and you're kind of like wow this
is shocking but nobody doesn't hit the
line that Shamblin wanted to I think cuz
the whole movie is so funny but it's
like it's bad and funny and so wouldn't
these kids are getting killed you're
like know how to feel about this
actually is it disturbing or just kind
of funny or am i disturbed because I
think it's funny so after the kids die
they actually kind of hang out for like
a minute the girls still on the porch
and Wahlberg is like sad about it and
you're like you might want to get away
from this guy who's taking a shotgun and
just sticking it out of his windows and
stuff you might want to get away from
that area then we get this needless News
reporter exposition where it tells us
what's going on in the world because
without that we wouldn't know what's
going on in fact there's a lot of news
reporter exposition in this movie I
hated movies where someone just stands
up and goes here's the information you
need to know audience because you are
too dumb to figure out these plot points
on your own I will tell them for you
because I'm reading from this script I
hope you figured it out thank you pretty
soon they stumble upon an old house
welcome to the crazy old lady house
sounds like a goosebumps title Wahlberg
just kind of stands there and stares at
this woman she's like why you I in my
lemon drink
I suppose the nice thing to do would be
to let you stay for supper come in I'm
not gonna ask you again man it was
really easy to be invited into the house
of someone who's been completely cut off
from society for decades who just allows
any random person to enter her house and
makes dinner for that person when they
do not say a single word but that's okay
because if she hadn't done that then we
wouldn't get this scene I hear you
whispering planning on stealing
something no man we're not planning on
murdering me in my sleep
what no I love that scene what no now
one of the biggest WTF moments of this
movie is when he wakes up the next
morning and goes in her room and sees a
doll like it's just a doll in her bed
like this really weird wooden doll the
weird thing is is he's literally
approaching the bed where anyone on
earth would be able to at this point see
that that is a small wooden doll and he
goes mrs. Jones no Wahlberg it's
really not mrs. Jones it's a doll so she
flips out she sees him she flips out
she's like you all have to leave right
now just right now get out of here right
now and she goes crazy and trust me she
starts giving off some bad vibes because
when she goes outside even though she's
completely by herself the plants they
don't like that they take over her mind
and they forced her to kill herself by
smashing her head through various
windows now listen it's very clear at
this point that M night Shyamalan is
trying to tell us that humans are giving
off bad vibes has nothing to do with
groups it's got nothing to do with that
you're a human you give off bad vibes
the plants they don't like that they're
gonna kill you
so that old lonely depressed lady who's
been living alone and cut off from
society who's been growing her own food
and taking care of her house and all
that stuff that has nothing to do with
harming the earth you're actually
cultivating the earth and making it
better she must have been really giving
off some bad vibes out in her garden at
that moment for the plants to be that
upset with her so Wahlberg realizes that
Zooey Deschanel and the little girl are
in the small little shed there's a
speaking tube under the ground into the
house and he's able to communicate with
him through there he's thinking the
plants are getting more sensitive and
this could be the end he looks at his
mood ring his ring is yellow he starts
to cry now this is what I was talking
about earlier in the movie where the
little girl put the mood ring on and it
turned yellow she was about to cry in
that moment but he was able to convince
her to laugh now that's kind of good
writing that's kind of cool that he made
that connection with the end of the
movie that's neat writing nevertheless
this movie's amazingly bad so he's
saying you know what I think this is it
but I don't want to say goodbye to you
through this tube we're gonna go outside
and we're gonna meet each other so they
do then we get an exact time stamp in
the bottom of the screen where
apparently it all happened because we
know the exact time that I don't know
it's crazy can I just say who shot this
shot look at this shot it's completely
off-center nothing what like her face is
cut off that is in the movie I have not
cropped that at all this is a shot from
the movie who looked at that and said
yeah that's the one we're using tack
Fujimoto was the director of photography
for this movie he was also the DP for
signs he's a very good cinematographer
what happened to that shot I don't even
know but that just kind of shows you
what this entire movie is it's people
that are kind of half-assing it and that
shot proves it so we get some more
News reporter exposition apparently it
just ended I mean it just that's it the
plants decided you know what we're done
which harkens back to that opening scene
where Wahlberg was like books will give
a reason but science won't be able to
explain it it'll just be like a random
event we'll have no idea what happened
thanks for spoiling the entire movie in
that opening scene appreciate it this is
News reporter who's talking and acting
like Woody Allen basically tells us you
know we don't really know it's like a
rash it's the first sign of a bad event
it's gonna grow it's gonna happen again
it's like a rash so as the little girl
prepares for school she's wearing her
avatar backpack and then the bus number
is 2010 the last airbender came out in
2010 so when Zooey Deschanel looks at
her pregnancy results we see that they
have plants behind them really after the
epidemic that killed thousands of people
because the plants got pissed at
humankind you're gonna put some plants
in your house maybe that's not a good
idea she's pregnant they're happy hugs
wonderful we cut to France French people
are now getting affected by and the one
magic person who's probably not giving
off bad vibes notices before everyone
else yet again odd happening it's such a
terrible terrible movie but it honestly
is very entertaining I gotta say I do
watch this movie maybe once or twice a
year just because it's so funny and
enjoyable to watch in that way it's not
a good movie though but it is pretty
hilarious so guys this has been my third
installment in my hilarious 'ti segments
I hope you did check out my reviews of
The Wicker Man with Nicolas Cage and the
room those are on my channel right now
if you want to check them out
as always guys thanks so much for
watching I'll be back with more of these
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuff my nice
you